a check-in with the contact tracing app
for england and wales it's been going
two weeks
has 16 million downloads and was used
for 1.5
million check-ins in a single day it's
supposed to warn you if there's an
outbreak
in a place you visited but
does it when we went through the code of
the app
we found that only one alert had been
set
about outbreak in a venue the contact
racing part of all this seems to be
working well
but the checking part seems well
dormant successful check-in upstream
lively look at that
the government has rolled out its
biggest guns to sell the check-in system
but at a time when pubs and bars are at
risk of mass
closure in parts of the country mps are
struggling to see the benefit
businesses that i've been speaking to in
my constituency had invested a lot of
money
in adapting to the new guidelines
ensuring the um
their staff are protecting the members
of the public are protected and this is
to ensure that consumer confidence
increases so that more people
can go out in their restaurants shop in
their businesses
and unfortunately the lack of
transparency
and the lack of efficiency in terms of
getting this right is really affecting
public confidence
to send an alert about a venue test and
trace put that place on a so-called
risky venue list the list is anonymized
and sent to the app
if any of the venues on the list match
the ones the phones checked into
that'll trigger an alert looking through
the code of the app
we uncovered the text of that
notification
it says we are letting you know that you
may have been exposed to coronavirus
when you are out
although there is only a small risk that
you have been infected during your visit
please continue to follow the latest
advice on social distancing
then it asks people to watch out for
symptoms a message
epidemiologists aren't sure is very
persuasive
nothing has no value but certainly
it probably from what you describe it
almost certainly can't be relied on to
effect to be a really
important and effective way of
controlling the epidemic
a department of health and social care
spokesperson told us
alongside the app's contact tracing
features
the qr code check-in system performs a
number of important functions
not least providing a digital diary for
users to prompt them as to who they have
been with
should they test positive there are
other oddities about the app
like the fact that it keeps your lunch
venue checked until midnight
for anyone hoping to check out from the
pandemic
it's not clear this is the tool that
will make the difference
roland manthal sky news